[Music]  [Applause]  first up first up we've melded Rachel  Maddow and Justin Bieber see what  happens  I love the screaming on part and stuff  that's you know not a bad thing  [Applause]  [Music]  first first lady Michelle Obama and Mike  Tyson  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Laughter]  okay good one all right ladies and  gentlemen you asked for it we delay  actually didn't ask for it you voted and  we're giving it to you Anne Hathaway and  Lord Voldemort  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  time to die on to God let's hear your  forth more you have a good one time to  die  [Music]  I dream to dream and finally ladies and  gentlemen Sarah Palin and honey boo boo  [Applause]